good morning everyone welcome back to
day three
of our accessible computer science
education fall workshop
thank you all very much for sticking it
sticking it out
and hanging in there and uh hopefully
it's all been worth the effort um i know
yesterday we made a lot of progress on
those
white papers um and i expect we'll make
even more progress
uh today um i will have a few short
announcements
after the speakers about what happens
after this workshop
um but before we get to that i just want
to make sure that everyone knows
about the hashtag that we have for those
who are interested in amplifying what's
going on here and what happens after it
you should be able to see that in the
chat window in
your view of the talks hashtag acsed
wkshp accessible computer science at
workshop
okay without any further ado i'd like to
introduce ruth farmer
ruth is from cs for all and she'll be
talking to us
about empowering all k-12 students to
learn computer science
take it away ruth good morning
and thank you everybody for all the work
you've done this week to
move this agenda forward it's so so
important to
all the work that we're doing at cs4l so
as roy said i am ruth farmer i'm chief
evangelist at cs for all we are
the national organization that's sort of
the umbrella and the big tent
for the computer science education
movement and
um i wanted to include this picture of
this
little girl this was from a mesa
conference i attended and i spoke and i
had this little robot with me
and then at the end i um i just handed
it to this little girl and you
thought i had like given her the moon
she was so excited and it's really
um a pleasure that i have in my work to
be able to um
travel around the country and meet the
people who are working so hard on
computer science education like yourself
and and see how you are empowering kids
of all kinds
so cs4 all is an organization of
now more than 700 organizations this
picture was actually taken our first
launch year and i think at the time we
had 200 members and now we have hundreds
more
and you know you can see here all the
banners of the different sponsors and
partners
it's grown so much into a huge huge
national community
working on this from all different
pieces of the puzzle
right there's a whole lot of different
inputs that go into
a 12-year sequence of computer science
education
for all kids and lots of organizations
working together which
i like to talk about as like the long
tail of computer science education
where there's a few big players that are
doing big things
but really this gets done by the
thousands of little inputs by
local teachers organizations and leaders
working
on specific aspects of the issue
so cs4l does three primary things we
support local change so we know this is
local
change is local permanent change is
certainly local so we support
organizations in building capacity to
deliver
evidence-based computer science we
increase
rigor and equity so we want to make sure
that the computer science that
is delivered in the system that is built
for this nation
is equitable and rigorous so
it's wonderful to be like oh a million
kids played this game but that's not
rigorous computer science education
we're looking at what makes this
something that
is scaffolded over time is
educating kids in a sequence that's
going to give them
all the resources they need to be
successful
and then finally we grow the movement so
we're looking to
i like to say it's my job to invite
everyone to the table and get more
people to the table
or rather it's my job to um convince
others that computer science is their
job
which is a fun thing to do so a little
bit of history and this all started
actually
many years before president obama talked
about it
obviously president obama wasn't going
to
launch a new stem initiative in the last
year of his administration unless it had
legs
and the reason that computer science for
all was the final stem initiative of the
obama administration
had a lot to do with all the work that
had been done by the community for the
prior
decade and more to get computer science
um moving and start messaging about the
need for this and to disaggregate stem
there was a long long term conversation
about stem
but people hadn't really broken it apart
to say you know look 70
of that stem that we're talking about is
actually tech and engineering
not biological science and earth science
and
it's not that those topics are not
important they are important it's that
computer science is missing
so i like to say you know that um
the t and the e right if we were to
write stem out it's really like a giant
s a tiny t tiny e and a big m
in terms of how we're putting resources
towards it at the federal level
and um and from the community so we're
trying to kind of
even that out um so as many of you know
in january of 2016
president obama included a mention of
computer science in his
um state of the union he said in the
coming years we should build on that
progress
offering every student the hands-on
computer science and math classes that
make them job ready on day one
so that was a big signal to the nation
and then on
january 30th they announced the computer
science for all initiatives
and um at that time announced 125
million of immediate federal dollars
and a four billion dollar budget request
into fy 2017 for computer science
education
and that had everybody really excited
but as you probably know
the incoming republican congress did not
even pass the budget for fbi 2017 until
april of 2017 so unfortunately that um
was a very aspirational number that
didn't come to pass
um as is usually the case with congress
in an election year
um but in the time that i was in the
white house
working on computer science for all um
more than 500
so 548 organizations i actually
stepped up with commitment to move the
needle for computer science education
which we felt was a huge win
and really resulted in um a lot of
of grassroots movement um so
cs4l the organization launched
officially at the
white house in september of 2016. this
is a picture of all of us
standing on the steps these are the um
the navy steps that are directly across
from the um from the uh
west wing entrance and this shows
all the people that had come to that
event but we also had
people from all over the country making
commitments that were tuning in
and i believe there were 170 000 people
on the live stream that day which is
one of the powers of like live streaming
something from the white house i think
you can't really beat that so
ps4 as an organization we are focused on
computer science for all students and
we strongly believe um that including
students with disabilities is critical
to our mission
and you can see here that this is from
code.org
report on the state of computer science
education that this is
11 states data that
students with disabilities are only
participating in computer science
classes at 59
of their representative population so we
clearly have a lot of work to do
in addressing this and cs4 as an
organization
cares a lot about the equity piece of
things and really value our partnership
with
the accessibility community and making
this a reality
so one of the ways that we're doing that
is in 2018 in partnership
with um the access computing
access cf brawl program that dr richard
lather leads
and many of the people that are probably
on in this room if i could see you
um launched the cs brawl accessibility
pledge
and um we used our
big tent and our annual convening power
to draw attention to the fact that
cs education is largely exclusive
or not accessible in the new tools that
are being developed
the curriculum and um first we put out a
blog
that called for organizations to make
their
resources and tools born accessible and
then we called for organizations to sign
a pledge
and that pledge was different depending
on your organization in some cases if
you were a funder it's
are you paying attention to the
accessibility accommodations of those
you are funding
um or is that a criteria of your funding
and if you were say a curriculum
developer or a tool provider you know is
it in
baked into your software is it part of
your design
um from that to you know if you're an
after school program are you
up front letting families know that you
can make accommodations for students
with disabilities
so we have this pledge and it was signed
by actually 105 organizations
um so the purpose of the pledge is we cf
thrall along with our
advisory board are supporting the
national community of computer science
education
content providers and institutions in
making their current and future products
and programs accessible
for students with disabilities and
learning differences
um another you know our three goals are
we want to raise awareness of these
issues
provide ongoing support to our pledge
takers and engage with the broader
community
the outcomes of this so far have been
pretty awesome
and we have um 105 content providers
that have made this commitment
and we're continuing to take new
pledge takers so you can see here is a
map that shows
where all these organizations are so all
over the country
um lots and lots of activity and many of
these organizations obviously serve kids
on a national level
um but our goal ultimately is that
everyone should be thinking about this
and including this in their work
we have an advisory committee made up of
a
wonderful set of national leaders that
are working on this
and um and this program is actually
sponsored has been sponsored so far for
the last two years
by northrop grumman foundation to
support
cs for all supporting others in thinking
about and acting on accessibility
and you can see here this is a picture
of a bunch of our
accessibility advisory board members
kind of hamming it up at the cs4l summit
back in 2018.
so um some updates on what we've
achieved so far
in march of this year we featured a blog
um
you know in response to the covid crisis
specifically
on education accessibility for students
with disabilities and so
um reached out to our community of
experts and
published some advice and resources for
schools districts and parents
on how to make sure that if kids are
participating in remote education that
they're still
getting access in july of this year we
did a webinar
featuring accessibility commitments um
from our community that you know we're
updating on
and that included um uw's access cs4l
program and the national girls
collaborative project
then this october we led a session on
accessible cs at the 2020
international theme summit that was led
by lender workshop
and that had a 6 000 person global
audience
and then literally day before yesterday
we hosted um
the cs brawl commitment showcase we had
about 8 000
attendees for that and um
accessibility accessibility advocate
daryl chill mitchell
who had actually joined us during the um
the launch in 2018
joined again to talk about accessibility
and
um i don't know if jeff kid's code is in
the audience but we were able to also
feature a member of deaf kids code as
one of our
question askers so we did a segment
in the in the event where we had
kids asking mitch resnick the founder of
scratch questions
about um the program and we um
included this young man his name is
jabril from deaf kids code and he asked
his question
and which was a very good question
actually um and
um introduced himself and asked his
question
and so you know we're making making
efforts to make sure that the
messages we're putting out are inclusive
and um
also i've uh much to her chagrin
made our our new communications manager
go back through
everything we have done in the past and
make sure there's
alt text and other accessibility
accommodations in our messaging and
resources
so what is next for us um and i believe
really put that link to that video in
the chat i encourage you to watch it
it's really charming
um so what's next for us we are on
tagging
accessibility focused and compliant
organizations
in our cs4 member directory so the cs4l
member directory
you can search for organizations that
are doing computer science education
by audience by age level by
topic and if they have taken the
accessibility pledge
and they answer some criteria questions
we can tag that they
are an organization that is paying
attention to that and we're using that
as an incentive
to get organizations to move on this um
we are integrating accessibility rubrics
and tools into the script
workshop so the script workshop is the
workshop with school districts to help
them build strategic plans
for computer science so um we're working
with our script team to bring um rubrics
in to make sure that
school districts are considering
accessibility in that design process
we're elevating and highlighting
organizations that are meeting
accessibility goals through
blogs and webinars and other events
and then providing technical support and
referral services for organizations
seeking to improve accessibility of
their programs and products and
approaches
um so we look forward to partnering with
all of you in that work because
you know oftentimes i will get an
organization that reaches out to me that
says hey i've got a kid with a
disability
and it's really great to be able to
connect with folks from the community
who have expertise
in those particular needs
so what can you do to join and be part
of
us i really really strongly invite you
to register to be a member of cf sprawl
we have
um members of all types including
researchers as well as
organizations at the district level or
curriculum creators and
funders all kinds of organizations are
members it's no cost you can just go to
member.cs4all.org to sign up
we have a slack channel that is
basically for the entire community
and we have a sub channel on
accessibility so
really encourage you to join there
obviously love to have you join our
accessibility pledge as well
and then we have a newsletter that's
really um pretty frequent
and you're welcome to contribute items
to be shared with our
community which i say is around the 12
000 mark um and um
obviously you can follow us on twitter
facebook
instagram and medium um or contact
us if you want to talk more so
this this is me and you are more than
welcome to email me contact me
and let me know if you have any
questions and
actually you guys are all the experts in
this but um
one thing i just want to like close with
is just that
the computer science education system
for the us
and for the world is being built right
now as we speak
flying the plane while we while we build
it and so
i don't think it could be more urgent to
make sure that we get accessibility
right from the beginning
because anytime you're trying to add
something in later to a system systems
are very sticky
and so this has to be um
we're already a bit behind the gun on
this so i think um
this deserves much much more attention
and i'm committed to making sure it gets
the attention it needs because
we have um we just can't afford to build
a bigger version of an
unacceptable business like if we're
going to get to for all it really truly
has to be for all at the ground level so
i really appreciate
all of you um doing this and your
partnership and helping us
make this a reality thank you
and thank you ruth for doing all the
work that you and cs for all are doing
um we do have a question in before we
get to that i might
seize the microphone myself our breakout
group has been looking at
sort of uh the role of curriculum in
making
uh cs ed available for all um and we've
started to spend a little time thinking
about the
lower primary or even pre-primary or
pre-k levels
i wonder if you've got any thoughts on
on that age
demographic yeah so
i think one of the um the really
challenging thing
with um with the early grades
is um you've got
for the most part we have
most teachers graduating college without
any foundational knowledge of computer
science
in the first place right so you're
looking at training teachers post
you know once they're in the workplace
so um
getting curriculum training to them
um at that level becomes a much bigger
distributed problem than if you were
doing it at the
pre-service level so one thing i would
say is if you're developing curriculum
at the grade level collaborate with the
colleges of
education to start to bring that in at
the pre-service training level
so it's part of all of that training
they're getting just to become a teacher
in the first place
and and thinking about the accessibility
pieces of that um
are you thinking are you talking more
about like developing curriculum
or or modifying curriculum that's
already been developed
we haven't gotten to that level of of
thinking yet
um yeah there's a lot of stuff that's
been built
right so lots of lots of stuff like
scratch
tinker lots of stuff has been built and
and the problem i think is that many of
those things have um
are pretty embedded and and hard to
compete with so one thing i i would
recommend thinking about is
how do you create curriculum that
leverages those big platforms but create
the accommodations and modifications
that
are um going to make it easy for for
educators to deliver to all their
students
and um because you're you're just going
to have a hard time
competing with the 100 million dollars
of edtech
venture capital that's been put into um
the sort of for-profit platforms that
are that are out there
yeah okay thanks we do have uh a bunch
more questions for you
um the first one is uh can you say a
little bit more about the accountability
for the accessibility tagging
in the cs for all directory to make sure
that they're actually following the
pledge
yeah so that is a hard one and we're
looking at that and that's
um for those of you listening that are
on our accessibility advisory board
we're going to be bringing that task to
you
um because um
going from a big tent to a you know
how are you checking and and
and reviewing and all of that is really
challenging so
um we are um really early stage in that
process
and part of it is how do we describe
what they're doing um
and what are the things we're expecting
them to do so
one thing is they need to explicitly
have some kind of accessibility
statement on their website that we can
point to
you know if we're referring people to
them and they say that they care about
this they need to have that clearly
stated
um so we'll be working with our advisory
consortium
um board members to develop a set of
criteria
that are on the front end before you get
your tag
in my opinion that's how i'm looking at
it
right uh okay our next question um
in addition to coding how are real world
and life skills included in the cs for
all approach
so um cs4l does not
teach coding right we're not an
organization that teaches coding or
teaches teachers to teach coding
um we are focused on
putting computer science education into
the system
um from my viewpoint computer science
as and i'm sure you guys all have heard
this we're not here to like create more
computer sciences
right we feel this is a foundational
skill that everyone needs to have
and that it's a matter of everyone
having the opportunity to have the doors
open to them for
whatever future they choose which could
include computing right
so that's um sort of the computer
science for all approach
so i think i really don't like the term
coding i think it's very very narrow
because it's a very
like it's the application of computer
science but really i like the word
computing
i like to talk about all the ways that
we are moving
and controlling and adapting
modifying information technology um
so you know data science is in there
obviously that's a
skill that can be applied in social
studies and lots of other areas
but siesta doesn't work directly with
kids and
we don't work directly with teachers we
work with organizations
and there's 700 of them so
across those we're covering all kinds of
different skill development
um and i feel like unfortunately the
word code has become a real
crutch because it's really so much more
than that
so you work with other organizations
that then interface directly with
teachers and students and
and all the different levels yeah
correct so like
like csta is a member of cs for all and
they work
directly with teachers um you know girls
who code
is a member of cs4l and they work
directly with girls
great okay we don't correct we don't
offer curriculum ourselves
right okay got it um uh
we have another question how do you
think the new administration might
change the landscape for cs for all
what are some actionable activities
you're pursuing as an organization
in addition to seeking pledges from
partners
yeah so um i'm pretty hopeful about the
new administration
um i i have a little bit of insider
knowledge so i am
i'm confident that they are a um a stem
positive and a cs positive
um science positive group of people that
are going to be
working on this and um you know the
um the efforts to get
um the community moving
um i think will just be more in
collaboration
with the administration so you know the
way that the cs for all
commitments work um is
there's a couple of things about
commitments one is we want
organizations so we have our pledge
that's
the cs4l accessibility pledge which is
about
making what you're doing accessible to
all kids and we also have something
called cs4
commitments and those are ways that um
an organization can step up and kind of
put a flag in this end and say we're
going to do
x for y population by the
date kind of thing um and that's one of
the ways that we measure
impact um and measure what's going on in
the country
because there's not a lot of really
great data collection at the national
level on
computer science education or the
accessibility or availability of it
i'm looking forward to you know
now that we have 700 members it's really
easy
for us to package up messages and come
together the community to share messages
with the administration
and and work with them to highlight what
we're doing and try to drive action
so i think there's going to be um lots
of opportunities going forward
great um we've got one more question and
if we can
answer this one quickly we might be able
to try and share that video that you um
that you that we have the link for um
the last question that we have
is what is a good balance in your
opinion between focusing on
making the curriculum accessible versus
the tools themselves
um so i think the tools absolutely need
to be accessible
absolutely and frankly i don't think
legally a school district should really
even be purchasing tools that aren't
accessible
so um i i'd love to see some
some effort on the part of the federal
regulators as well as the state folks
to you know make this an issue and
um you know millions of dollars of
venture capital is going into creating
tools and it is
like ridiculous that they might create
something that's not accessible
so i think um you know and
broadly lots of people are doing this
badly
across the entire internet like lots of
people are doing this badly
and um i just noticed recently that um
i think it was medium or twitter had
added the ability
to um to add alt text to your talk
to your pictures but it's limited to 250
characters or limited name characters
i'm like why would you limit the number
of characters anyway
so go ahead with the video i just want
to share this is ms resnick founder of
scratch
taking a question from a student from
deaf kids code
all right let's play that video what's
the next question
yeah our next student says hi
my name is jabril
i'm a student at the pennsylvania school
for the deaf
and
one of the first cadets for deaf kids
code
i'll be teaching scratch to other deaf
kids soon
i love coding and hope to become a tech
founder myself someday
my question for mitchell is how did you
think of
the big is to invent scratch
i mean it's big work hard work and a
dream maybe a passion
how did you get everything you needed to
successfully invent scratch
thanks gabriel first of all let me just
say i'm just
really impressed with the work that
you're doing in teaching other kids to
code
that seems like really important work
and it's great that you're doing that
i also really love your question because
i love the way that you
recognize the importance to passion
that passion is the key to success and
work on big projects
and i really agree with you because i
think when we're passionate about
something
that we're willing to work longer and
harder
and persist in the face of challenges
and difficulties
so i think that if you really want to
succeed at something you need to be
passionate so you're willing to push on
and keep working at it and i think those
of us working on scratch
have been really passionate about it
because we really care about providing
new opportunities for kids
we want to help kids be able to create
new things
and to learn new things so that passion
for us
is what keeps us going and coming up
with new ideas for scratch
i think one other key to success on the
project is that we brought together a
team
that was diverse in lots of different
ways we came from different disciplinary
backgrounds we had computer scientists
and educators
and psychologists and child people from
child development
and design we have lots of different
types of background
and i think that type of diversity is
critical
to creativity and success in big
projects
let's see the next question awesome
thanks so much
yeah thank you ruth um it's uh
very um spot on to let your passions
drive your interests like that
um thank you again for your your great
talker
seeing you guys youtube